now you're a director I mean this this
was this one that I saw that I mean if
you do one you're still
considered you you there may may not be
repeat business but certainly yeah yeah
no I think there will be I mean I I
enjoyed it a lot and it's funny you know
it's about this Italian family but like
in the sitcom you didn't play up the
Italian part all that much this family
yeah there I mean dinner at noon what
the is
that is that your is that your real I
think they started intermittent fasting
the Italians you know cuz what what is
that dinner at noon thing and is that
what your family was your real family
well here's the thing the the the family
that I wrote the movie about is the one
I married into I married into that I'm
Italian I grew up in New York I see my
parents are from this were born here
though but my wife's parents came right
over on the boat and um didn't speak
English and that's the Universe I wanted
to write about and yes on Sunday dinner
was around noon yes that's true it's a
listen it sounds like a cliche and some
of the characters we thought are we are
we stereotyping too much but it was when
I started dating my wife I know this is
going to sound like a a
stereotype like week two I called her
house up and I said is Anna home it's Ry
and her mother spoke broken English and
she said no you know no home and I said
you just tell her the Ray called and she
goes okay you hungry on the phone
I know it sounds it sounds like it but
on the phone you wanted to know if I was
hungry so that's what I WR I wrote about
what I knew and I knew I've known that
for 30 I've been married 35 years
[Applause]
so that's a mock clap no no it's just
odd to me that two people who are like
around the same age 40 yeah um oh you
and
yeah of course um um who like had very
similar East Coast upbringings I mean I
I of course I a neighborhood a lot of
Italian people and I I didn't really see
them that much in the neighborhood at
school I was a delivery boy for the
local liquor and Drug Store there's like
three stores in town right and I
delivered for two of them and I would so
I would see Italians in their natural
habitat
at my My First Girlfriend Was
Italian yeah you grew up in New Jersey
right or County New Jersey yeah yeah no
I mean look I used to but how did we
become so different with such similar
age and background well we we're the
same in some some ways right we com like
to Performance stand up you're smarter
you're much smarter no you
are well we'll see who we'll see who's
richer and then we'll find out
who
I think I win that I'm not sure I know I
think you probably do I I'm pretty sure
you do but neither one of us are
complaining I don't think no no no but
but I think it's a testament to you that
a guy like me watches your show every
every week because you of course you
have the intelligent audience but you
cross over you have the dumb audience
too